the twitter bluescoop which i'll unpack
for a moment here
uh this was um reported on twitter by an
app researcher named
jane wong she is wang m
jane w-o-n-g-m-j-a-n-e and she released
this on may 15th on saturday
and uh she said the initial features uh
will include the ability to bookmark
tweets into collections that sounds a
lot
like moments so maybe you know which is
a product they removed
but i kind of like that product it was
kind of neat um
in a leaked screenshot it says take your
twitter experiences to the next level
with exclusive features collections
save and organize your favorite tweets
and collections so they're easier to
find later
so the idea here would be you know they
have lists they never really
finished list they never made that a
great product that was a huge missed
opportunity
i think lists should become something
that twitter makes as part of this or
advanced lists there's so many different
things you can do with advanced lists
and uh maybe when you hit the star or
bookmark you could then
save these tweets even if they get
deleted uh or republish them pretty
interesting
and the screenshot of collections and
bookmarks in actions
looks as you would expect it you add and
remove a tweet to a collection
it does a little pop-up and you put it
in there no no big deal
maybe they'll have an undo tweet button
with a timer kind of like
undo send in emails if you use
superhuman which we're investors in
when you send your email it holds it for
10 seconds you get a little bottom thing
on the bottom that says
undo it on any action whether you're
archiving deleting or even
sending composing and then sending and
that's pretty nice to
have that there's a leaked gif of in
fact the undo tweet
um it says your tweet was sent and
there's an undo button uh
and when you look at that gif it's kind
of uh like a little status bar uh that
fills up you know if you click it you
can then
undo your tweet and so i guess twitter
is going to make you pay
to have that feature um and
uh clutter free news reading better news
aggregation is also mentioned here
and when we get to the acquisition
section one of the companies we invested
in
which i don't have inside information on
might be part of this vision we'll see
um it remains to be seen but they are
planning perhaps multiple tiers here
with more premium features for higher
tiers so 299
699 and you know 29.99 might be
what they do here just like when you buy
any sas software
according to wong this twitter blue
screenshot is a work in progress is not
final
things like the name pricing features
etc may change ahead of official watch
but i'm sure the features that will grow
as time grows so who knows um how she
got this information
but she obviously has somebody who
leaked it to her i'm assuming she
did not dumpster dive for these in the
uh trash bins behind
the twitter headquarters because it's
closed or due to pandemic and i'm
assuming she didn't hack their system